At the heart of every experiment there's a good question. And these questions
come from observation. I've been observing my co-workers here at Audacity,
drink coffee every single morning right when they come in. I want to know why.
So, I think there might be a good experiment there. I'm going to wait here
until somebody comes, so that I can figure out what's going on. We've got
someone. Good morning, Andy.
&gt;&gt; Good morning, Lauren.
&gt;&gt; How are you?
&gt;&gt; fine.
&gt;&gt; I see you're making coffee. You drink a lot of coffee. Why is that?
&gt;&gt; it makes me more effective in the morning, I work better and faster I guess.
&gt;&gt; Are you saying that it decreases your reaction time?
&gt;&gt; No, I didn't say that, but I guess yeah, I guess it probably increases my
reaction time.
&gt;&gt; You mean decreases. Do you want me to stop asking questions this early in the
morning?
&gt;&gt; That would be, that would be fine.
&gt;&gt; Well, thank you, Andy. I think I have an idea for a good experiment. I'll see
you later.